[Music]
hi I'm Judy I live in Houston Texas I
work for a health plant
I like to salsa dance and spending time
with my friends it is just me I'm the
only one in my immediate family that is
down here in Houston I am single and in
Houston it can be difficult not to say
that my family isn't supportive but you
know across the miles it's hard coming
to the University of Houston there was a
lot of student loans that accumulated
over the years a co-worker of a previous
position she had the Dave Ramsey book
and so I was interested in kind of asked
her a little bit more about it when I
started the Dave Ramsey program actually
had just purchased a car and just
purchased some living-room furniture so
I was really starting to step back after
I did the first Financial Peace
University course I was able to pay off
my card debt but after that I knew I had
a huge mountain to climb with a student
loan again just doing this on my own I
had no one to convince what myself
there were times where I had to convince
myself but I knew that I don't want to
be the only beating heart in my house I
want a dog and it's just me and by
myself I want a dog and the kind of dog
that I want a German Shepherd can't live
in an apartment I knew at that point
that I really just needed to clean up my
situation I understand that for most
people they usually have a bigger goal
in contrast yeah it was kind of a funny
motivation for me to have a dog believe
it or not it was what spurred me you
know through it all I do know that I had
five different gig at a time I
like to dance specifically salsa it was
great I was able to use my interest than
my talent it's all part of it
again you just you know I would say yeah
just keep your head down keep pluggin
like plugging in or nearly that settle
again pull you through I was coming home
from my photobooth gig I heard a noise
in the back of my car
of course I have all of the equipment in
my car again it's slightly raining at
midnight I thought maybe the equipment
shifted or something and I realize I've
seen Shauna I called the police so when
we were assessing the damage there was
12 shots that were put into my car I had
to use my emergency fund to help repair
the damage to my car the different
panels in my car and then of course the
windshield and I was very mad because
again I'm here it's just me I'm working
at 12:00 midnight this is my you know
second or third job today who are you to
really take away or threaten what I'm
working so hard for what gave me peace
was that this is just part of my story
everyone is going through something
everyone has you know something that's
happened and how are you going to deal
with that I've gone to too smart many
conferences and then also to Total Money
Makeover oh gosh I remember going to
those and I was so stoked just even
being in the parking lot really with the
last two years or so of my debt again
I'd really just started kicking it into
high gear when it came down to pay off
my last payment
I was screenshotting that like no one's
business is this is done this was
definitely done so I paid off fifty
eight thousand dollars in four years I
worked five overlapping jobs throughout
that entire time I'm single it was up to
me and I did it and I will say the debt
free scream for me was always going to
happen I'm debt free
and free I have nothing holding back
it's going to be hard knowing that
identity easy just keep at it because
again at the end of the day it's just
you as a woman isn't it a great place to
be because there's so much out there you
really just have to go out and
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]